The Power of Perception.
Perception is a powerful thing in a social context.
People tend to follow what they perceive to be the 'social norm.'
For example, compared to a dry campus,...
...students tend to drink more at a college campus where heavy drinking is viewed as the normal thing to do.
The pressure associated with perceived social norms is huge.
Take a friend of mine for instance.
While in high school this fellow was as good as gold.
Straight A student, polite, with clear career goals in mind.
But in college, he joined a fraternity known for its heavy drinking,...
...and even this boy allowed social pressure to get the better of him...
...and he almost flunked out of college in his freshman year.
The power of perception cannot be underestimated even on an individual level.
Firemen tend to be viewed as being as brave as lions.
A new fireman, who actually might be quite frightened of the idea of rushing into a burning building,...
...might find himself actually doing that when confronted with the situation...
...because he knows that others expect him to do so,...
...and automatically perceive him to be a brave man because he is a fireman.
Except for a few strong-willed people,...
...most succumb to the powerful persuasion of social expectation.